hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation precise gene editing of
human pluripotent stem cells presented
by dr. Chris AHA assistant professor in
the department of biomedical engineering
at the University of wisconsin-madison
I'm Marian Burkhart check of thermo
Fisher Scientific and I will be your
moderator for today's presentation
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we do encourage you to participate by
submitting any questions you may have at
any time during the presentation just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and type
your question into the drop-down box
that appears on the screen will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know of any
technical difficulties I would like to
introduce and give you some background
on dr. Saha dr. Saha is an assistant
professor in the department of
biomedical engineering at the university
of wisconsin-madison he is a member of
the Wisconsin institutes for discovery
the Carboni Cancer Center and the stem
cell regenerative medicine centers as
well as the National Academies forum on
regenerative medicine
prior to his arrival in Madison dr. Saha
studied chemical engineering at Cornell
University and at the University of
California in Berkeley he was a Society
in science member of the Branco wise
fellow at the Whitehead Institute for
biomedical research at MIT and in the
Science and Technology Studies program
at Harvard University his major goals of
his lab are to involve gene editing and
gene engineering of human cells found in
the retina central nervous system and
blood I will now turn the presentation
over to dr. Saha thank you that's a very
nice introduction today I'll be talking
about engineering human pluripotent stem
cells a lot of this work is coming out
of projects supported by the National
Science Foundation as well as the
National Institutes for health in
particular there's a consortium somatic
cells genome editing consortium
and cell manufacturing technologies
Center that were part of for several
projects and on this image you'll see an
image of the cast nine protein together
with an RNA as well as a DNA template
that's a useful formulation that we use
and I'll be describing that strategy as
well as another strategy that seems to
work quite well in our hands for human
pluripotent stem cells
so I want to first give us
motivation here this community and I
assume the audience is very very
familiar with human stem cells but in
particular were focused on human
pluripotent stem cells that could be
derived from human embryos or through
reprogramming to make induced
pluripotent stem cells and these can be
patient specific so some of the
applications here have been to model
these diseases use them for drug
discovery use them for toxicology at the
stem cell state or after expansion and
differentiation as shown in this cartoon
what we've been interested in is using
this type of platform for testing genome
editing strategies there could be a
number of reasons why you want to do
this perhaps you want to change a
pathogenic variant that you've seen in
your core opponent stem cells to
understand its function or to provide an
interesting isogenic control for some of
these assays or they could be actually
useful as cell therapies or resources
for tissue engineering that actually get
transplanted into patients regardless I
think one of the ways in which our lab
has been working with these resources is
to think about how we could make better
genome editors using these human
cellular platforms so there's a number
of different ways and about one for here
on this slide first I think it provides
a benchmark and I mentioned correction
or knocking in or writing in new types
of genetic variants that you want to see
within your cell lines you can also
compare the effect of gene augmentation
side-by-side that could be through viral
vectors or other strategies it's also in
a relevant human system to think about
adverse events from applying high doses
of genome editors you can also test in a
patient specific manner here in three if
there are particular single nucleotide
polymorphisms or snips that could lead
to new recognition sites for genome
editors and lastly here you can think
about and explore the effects of host
factors that could vary from cell type
to cell ty
because you are working with a stem cell
platform that as the same genetic
sequence that you can differentiate to
either a progenitor stage or a mature
cell type stage and see whether it
matters and how it matters to do genome
editing at those different cell types
notably because the trafficking
machinery the receptors on these very
various cell types could be very as well
as DNA repair machinery that's relevant
for many of the nuclease basic genome
editors so I want to move here to the
system that we work with most often
which is the CRISPR cap 9 system UC is
an acronym for clustered regularly
interspaced short palindromic repeats
and calf nine is right now the most
common protein which is a CRISPR
associated protein that allows us to
specifically cut the genome and this
system is shown in cartoon form here on
the on the slide taken from the
reference at the bottom and it's really
coming from a bacterial immune system
that's used to degrade invading DNA i'm
not going to go through really the
details of the system since the review
is there is actually there's actually a
very good radio lab link that's on this
slide that describes the very
interesting story of how this system was
discovered and developed but regardless
to say there's a small short hairpin
like RNAs death
shown in Part B on the the top right
that rep gets recognized by Cass
CRISPR associated proteins that ends up
cutting foreign DNA and foreign DNA in
Part C is shown by the invading phage so
this system has been engineered to work
in human cells and it can cut
specifically based on the RNA sequence
and one cartoon here that illustrates
how the CRISPR system works the blue
protein here is cast 9 it's loaded with
a RNA that's recognizing the gray
genomic DNA sequence and what the calf
nine does is it makes a DNA double
strand break and this break can be
repaired by the cellular machinery
primarily through two DNA repair
pathways one is non-homologous end
joining which is labeled on the left
here as error-prone and joining and what
that results in is small on the order of
a few base pair insertions of random
bases or deletions of the ends of the
cut side that generate a wide spectrum
of sequences specifically where the cut
was made there's also the pathway on the
right called homology directed repair
and you see a differently colored strand
there that's labeled as SSO DN thus for
single-stranded all ago nucleotide and
if that's designed correctly such that
parts of it are homologous to the ends
of the cut site you can actually
incorporate the exact sequence that's
written into the exact sequence that's
on the template which is written into
the genome to give you an example of
what this looks like the wild-type
sequence here is on the top and the cut
that we make using the CRISPR system is
between the C and the a and you see a
lot of - why
serve and so the template that SSO DN in
this experiment is has the the wild-type
sequence but it has this blue knocked in
sequence that we're trying to write into
that specific spot and so all of the
outcomes here at the at the bottom the
blue as well as the orange are outcomes
that we get after we use this genome
editing system in human quarry bone stem
cells and you can see that we get in
some of our reads
the precise insertion of what we wanted
from the template that's in blue but we
also get these other reads and you could
have the insertion correctly but
upstream there's an underline see in
orange that is a mutation at that spot
you can also have a deletion at that
spot or you can get partial
incorporation which is the second from
the bottom we're about five bases or so
it have been deleted in the insertion
and then the very bottom any tj4
non-homologous end joining you can have
the ends to dawei from the cut side and
so if if you're trying to make a cell
line that that has this blue sequence
specifically at the cut side all of
these orange sequences can are are not
what you wanted and they could have
important differences from from what you
intended so we in our lab call this
precise versus imprecise editing and we
recently wrote a review that describes
precision in genome editing and what I
just described this highlighted is
number two here in this cartoon among
four different ways of thinking about
precision
the most common way that people think
about precision of genome editing
then to make a cut where you want it and
not cut elsewhere in the genome so these
other areas elsewhere in the genome have
been up described as off target sites
and a lot of the precision that you can
achieve using a specific cut have to do
with engineering the nucleus a little
bit of engineering the the guide
sequence in the CRISPR system that's
really not the focus of my talk today
we're much more interested in in part to
the other ideas of precision just to
describe the slide here is and three is
that you also want the edited sequence
to be expressed properly so you can you
should think also about precise
transcriptional control of your edited
sequence as well as another idea when it
applies to the body of editing the right
cell type in the right tissue so these
are all different ways at least in
literature you can see of precise genome
editing being described today's talks
and what I'll focus on is really number
two to be able to do the precise
sequence level knock ins or changes
where you're cutting
the two methods that we've we use
routinely now in the lab are a transient
Purim Ison selection method that I'll
talk about in the first half of my talk
and then secondly a RNAi simplex method
and this it takes advantage of an RNAi
optima that brings the donor template
together with the cutting machinery
so this first pure Meissen selection
method we've been using mostly on
chlorophyll and stem cells that have
come from patients with a number of
disorders and we focused on a specific
gene called best one in a retinopathy
this in the light green circle on the
bottom it's one of the genes implicated
and has been seen in patients that have
vision loss and what this gene is is
that it has and if you look at the
protein structure of best one you can
see a number of mutations in red and a
patient that's been diagnosed with this
typically has a autosomal dominant
mutation and
what we wanted to do in in our lab and
what we have done now is to specifically
fix some of these red mutations in the
stem cell lines that we get through
reprogramming each patient's blood
sample after we reprogram we also
generate retinal issues optic cups as
well as pigmented epithelial layers
these are the kind of two
tissue constructs that stimulates what
the retina is inside these patients this
is through a collaboration with David
gams lab here at uw-madison
and the very first times we try to fix
these mutations using some of the
standard CRISPR tools we have very low
efficiencies and we took a step back and
we started doing some studies on human
cell lines after delivery of the CRISPR
system and one way one study that
summarized here in the reference at the
bottom is that we loaded a calf 9 g of
PM RNA to encode that the cutting
machinery in vitro transcribed short
guide RNA and various types of
transfection materials and we did this
in kind of a medium throughput way such
that we can watch in cells that have
that that are receiving these packages
of the genome editors and we have this
platform where we can look over time at
the same cells in about small
subpopulations you can see on the right
these little dots on the surface of our
slide
have-have a salt-and-pepper type of
expression of em cherry and so the
system here and it's described in the
paper is that we have an EM cherry
fluorescent tags that we're trying to
edit and by watching the editing of them
Terry we can see which of these cells
and when do we get genome editing and so
that's summarized here we as I mentioned
on the top we're delivering basically
and all are in a form of genome of the
genome editor and because there's a GFP
fusion in this mRNA we can see where the
protein is and because the cells have a
EM cherry here in the genome as shown in
Part II whenever we get successful
genome editing and if we wait for
protein term turnover to happen we see a
loss of that M cherry if if the CRISPR
system is working and so what we found
is that if there's quite a bit of
heterogeneity and so some of these cells
get
quite a quite a bit of GFP that's shown
on the right and that since the
diffusion is also tagging cast nine and
then some at the top here get less
translation of GFP and they have less
editing and that's about four days after
delivery we see a lot more mm cherry in
these cells at the top meaning they
weren't as edited as the cells at the
bottom where you see mostly just blue
cells without that many em cherry
positive cells and so if you look at
thousands of these types of spots and
start to make correlations about which
materials can deliver effectively and
what doses of each of these components
the mRNA encoding casts nine as well as
the short guide RNA you can start to see
trends and this is again from the same
paper we see some of these transfection
reagents working quite well and when we
look in a quantitative way and try to
predict which cells will be edited based
on some characteristics of expression
and cell density we found that cells
that express caste 9 and translate class
9 early
have more gene-editing and we find that
cells that actually do not caliph rate
early so that's the delta cells on the
right as one of our coefficients in this
regression model in the first 24 hours
those also have higher editing and our
thought here is that there's probably a
stress that's induced by cutting of the
genome as perhaps also by delivery and
if we're able to identify these cells
that are slowing down but also have a
lots of cast 9 those are the ones that
would be edited most frequently
so we applied this to human free phone
stem cells these insights and we had to
change a little bit of how we how we
delivered the CRISPR system notably
because those mRNA formulations did not
work that well in humans or bones
themselves all of that work was with
human embryonic kidney cells but
regardless that I think the idea that
you deliver caste 9 at high levels early
after after delivery and then slow down
the cell cycle these are things that we
were able to achieve using a plasmid
form of that encodes the CRISPR system
so on the top left here there's a
plasmid that has cast 9 expressed with a
to a sequence and then a pure my sense
resistance gene packed and so whenever
cast nynex is expressed and also
translated you will have this resistance
protein inside the cell we also co
deliver this single-stranded
oligonucleotide template and we rely on
electroporation or nucleus n to get all
of this into human for each one stem
cells and importantly here the pure mice
in here is not encoded on the donor and
that allows us to do only a transient
selection over the first four days or so
so we start at day one and we end at day
for three days of pure mice and
selection and
that's simply by adding pure myosin to
our media and on the right here you can
see a summary of our editing results
which is as you move from zero no pure
myosin in the media you get almost all
of yourselves is a very I think small
green bar there almost all of your cells
are not edited as you start increasing
selection increasing for the cells that
have high levels of past 9 you get more
homology directed repair that's the
precise editing outcome and more in
dough that's the imprecise editing
outcome and there's kind of a sleep but
where you get a four to one or or higher
type of ratio of the precise edited
clones versus the ones that have
imprecise edits and so a lot of the data
is summarized in this stem cell reports
paper that's listed at the bottom by a
talented now graduate student graduated
student bends there we also have been
looking in some of these
patient-specific these models that I
mentioned for the the best jeans and
we're able to look how specific the
CRISPR system is and because in some of
these cases for a dominant allele you
have one wild-type allele and a mutant
allele we can make and design CRISPR
genome editors to selectively degrade
one allele versus the other
so we have cells that are healthy from
healthy individuals where you have two
wild-type copies and in this case we're
delivering virus for the CRISPR system
in stem cells and this is an another
delivery system that works quite well if
you just want to cut the genome and rely
on imprecise genome editing this slide
is mostly to show that you can achieve
mutant specific allele editing where if
you make these guide RNA specific to the
mutant allele in blue or the sorry the
mutant allele in red and the wild type
of allele in blue you get editing a
shown on the y-axis specific to that
allele and you can also if you do
next-gen sequencing see which of these
edited alleles exactly what sequence you
get if it relates if it results in a
frameshift mutation that should result
in nonsense mediated decay if it's not
in the last that son of the gene
this is kind of
a pretty popular way that we've been
using on on stem cells for knocking in
variants where we have cells that grow
quite well from patients another
alternative is to use a learning Optima
that doesn't rely on on any plasmids or
mRNA the advantage here is that there's
probably a lower likelihood of random
integration of your plasmid into the
genome and if that's a concern for you
you could use potentially one of these
protein and short RNA based methods so
again to summarize we're still looking
at this challenge here of making more
precise reefs in the clothes that you
get and our strategy here was to think
about Co delivering the donor template
within with the cutting machinery and we
exploit this connection here this shown
in the cartoon that is called an s-1 M
Optima that's specifically shown in red
this Optima is from some studies in 2013
that found essentially a biotin mimic in
a short RNA sequence and the first
version of this was called s1 shown on
the left and the blot at the bottom
shows that one as you increase the
amount of streptavidin that would mimic
the bias and streptavidin binding you
get more and more binding of the RNA
after merida streptavidin there's a
modified version called s1 m that
stabilizes the stem part of this
structure and it has a higher affinity
for streptavidin and that's shown in red
so we took this knee twist and we looked
at the crystal structure of cast 9 and
together with the guide and found a few
places where we can introduce this
Optima we put it into a few stem lifts
and at the end and we call these version
1 s1 em sgrna 1 2 & 3
and we wanted to see if this actually
does bring together all the components
that we wanted to together and we relied
on this technique called dynamic light
scattering where you can look at the
correlation in intensity and determine
size of particles
after shining a laser in a solution of
them and this slide is a bit busy but I
want you to focus on the green trace
here that's shown and on the x-axis as
shown is the radius of the particles the
average radius and that's in nanometers
and on the y axis is normalized
intensity and so the the green is what
we call the simplex where it has the
after mer the cast nine the streptavidin
and whenever we take away one of the
components or multiple components we get
much smaller particles
we wanted to see whether these particles
stay intact inside the cell so we can
look at pluripotent stem cells after we
delivered to see some simplex s and we
can look by staining forecast nine
protein and streptavidin the two protein
components here on the top is a version
where we take away the after and on the
bottom here is the version where we have
the optima and there's more yellow dots
and speckles inside the nucleus
specifically of these cells
and this is a zoomed in version of the
same image and if we look at the
correlation of the the co-localization
of streptavidin cast nine whenever we
have the f1m optimum we get higher
correlation inside these cells and this
is described in this paper at the bottom
published last year
so does it matter where we put this
after myrrh it does to a moderate effect
in all cases after we deliver these
simplex --is into human for bone stem
cells we get an increase in the precise
editing outcomes and so you'll see a
number of these types of slides that
come from the paper where on the y-axis
you have a ratio of the precise over the
imprecise reads that we get in
sequencing after we sequence the cells
in this case it's about six days after
electroporation so the three different
after Merlo k shion's
and the three different simplices all
seem to increase the ratio of precise to
emphasize
putting the after Marin locations one
and two in the previous slide seemed to
help the best and so all of the data
from now on is by using app the app
number in position one and so we tested
it at a number of different low side
this is at the blue fluorescent protein
transgene where we've tried to switch
three nucleotides and this simplex seems
to help almost eighteen fold so now we
have four times on an absolute level of
precise reads to the in facilities and
then on we always compare against the
standard ways of delivering everything
without the after mark and
we've looked at larger knockin so 18
nucleotides and we've taken away
systematically other parts of the
complex only whenever we have the full
complex do we see the increasing
increase in precision
and we've also done it at
the EMFs one locus that's been used in
other genome editing studies
here we've looked at G a a is a team
that's involved in a disorder called
pompe disease the new-born disease and
we've kind of flipped this chart around
because we were playing with different
ways of modifying the single-stranded
all ago and where it could be designed
to have the DES biotin on the 3-prime
end or the 5-prime end or it could be
symmetric around the cut side or
asymmetric around the cut side all of
that data is not shown here but we did
not find a really obvious effect from
tethering the donor in various ways in
all cases when we Co delivered we had
about a 10 10 fold increase whenever we
use the simplex versus not and so on the
left portions of this graph you'll have
precision to imprecision ratios below 1
and whenever we use the simplex on the
right we get in the before 2 to 9 range
of precise reads for every imprecisely
some people wonder whether off-target
events are different when we use the
strategy and we look in a fairly limited
manner at live off target sites for
several of the simplex a--'s that we
made in most cases using this Sanger
sequencing method PCR amplify and flick
on Sanger sequencing method we refund we
don't find any obvious off target events
when we use our simplex in one case for
one off target in our emx one strategy
the standard way of doing genome editing
had some off target events so you know I
think more studies could be done but we
don't see a increase if not even
decrease in off target events
one of the other nice tricks that we can
do with our simplex is that we can bring
in other car goes because streptavidin
has four binding sites and we're only
using one for the donor we can attach a
quantum dot such that we can see where
these where the genome editing machinery
is and we can attach it through
different types of linkers and in one
case the linker did matter for how
effective the genome editing was
occurring one application of this has
been to make two different edits in the
same cell and what you can do is by
having a fluorescently tagged version of
script Abbadon you can have one CRISPR
machinery simplex here directed against
one locus in this case on the left the
green is against an AMX one locus with a
particular repair template and the red
simplex which is a red tag streptavidin
would be against a different locus in
the right here shown in blue for us and
proteins so if you mix these up and
execute that and then do electroporation
you can see some instances and of cells
that have the simplex Asst inside the
nucleus again if you do facts and try to
purify out cells that have both green
and red simplex is a double positive or
the red simplex is only or the green
simplex is only or no simplex and then
do sequencing in you'll see the the
expected trends in editing outcome so
the double negative have low amounts of
edits on both targets the green ones
have a lot more green precise edits and
no detectable
the red positive fraction had a lot more
red edits and lower green edits and then
the double positive had higher levels or
high levels of both a lot of this
depends on how stringently you gait but
at least you can enrich for the types of
edits that you're looking for
and so there's a kind of summary of I
think the types of outcomes that we get
when we use this system and I want to
kind of quickly go through in about a
few minutes here how we've applied this
system to a few cell lines one in
particular for pompes disease and I
mentioned pompe disease is this loss of
this GAA inside cells and the muscles in
these typically babies that are not very
strong because there's a buildup of
glycogen inside the lysosome if we're
able to edit them which we have been
able to do you would restore activity of
this ga8 in the lysosome and see more
glucose inside the cell and so these are
challenging edits to make because you
have two different mutations on on the
maternal and paternal copies of the
genome and so allele one here has a
mutation G to a mutation at this in red
and then the other allele has a mutation
earlier called a deletion of T so these
are compound heterozygous mutations and
so we design simplex a--'s that repair
both of these problems and we take
advantage of both of the platforms that
I talked about that high content
platform that was those spots
that I described about delivering mRNA
as well as this simplex and we were able
to isolate correctly isolate edited IPS
clones that had all of the markers of
pluripotency and when we did sequencing
had every possible repair here so you
could have a repair on one allele or the
other
you can have repair of both alleles and
I'm not going to go through all of these
sequencing traces because of time but it
is it is the sequencing traces look as
expected by looking at these two alleles
we also wanted to check that we're not
causing a large-scale genomic deletion
or insertion and we did this by doing
some long-range PCR and that was done
across both of the mutations and in all
cases we saw the bands as expected no
problems in karyotypes and proper
pluripotency markers
so one thing that you can do is see that
this edited alleles are properly
expressed and it's a little challenging
to show but we've done some deep
sequencing of mRNA and we actually see
in blue over representation of the
edited allele so when when we sequence
in this case at exon 9 so at the
mutation on a wheeeeel one we see over
representation of the edited allele in
the mRNA
and when we look and beep sequence at
the mutation location for allele 2 we
see a similar trend over representation
of the edited transcript and then we can
also look at the 3-prime junction in
that case we can distinguish which
allele is coming from we still we again
see a higher level when we do correct
both alleles one of the advantages of
doing this type of gene editing versus
doing gene augmentation is that you're
not flooding the cell with one single
open reading frame and you're
potentially can have native protein
processing at endogenous levels and
that's exactly what we see when we do
the Western blot
and in this case for Pompey disease we
are also interested in how much excess
enzyme gets secreted from cells and
we've differentiated these cells the
cardiomyocytes and we see actual
cooperativity meaning that we get a
synergy when we correct both alleles so
that's I guess a small story really
quick story of how you can do multiplex
editing to change in this case two
alleles in the same cell
so to summarize here because I want to
have some time for questions
I think chloroform stem cells can be an
important point clinical platform to
test genome editing strategies precision
can be increased by transient selection
or code delivery of a genome editor and
I think some of these reagents are nice
in that for the a primer case that they
can be quality controlled and developed
potentially as an offer shelf free agent
so I'll just end here by acknowledging
the team that really pushes forward
notably Jared Carlson sturb Rimmer who's
now at synth ago and Ben stair who is in
medical school as month
be happy to take any questions
thank you Chris for that great
presentation we can now begin with a
live Q&A portion of the webinar I do see
that we do have a lot of questions that
are already in queue but if you do have
a question you'd like to ask please do
so now by clicking on the ask question
drop-down box located on the far left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box it appears on the
screen and then click the send button so
let's get started I have a question here
first question um is have you reduced
the off-target effect significantly with
the use of the s-1 simplex yeah I showed
that slide where we saw less off-target
effects at one off-target site we don't
have you know each genome-wide
sequencing data so I'm hesitant to say
that that's going to hold up for every
particular strategy but I do think you
know if you there there are good studies
about limiting the amount of cast 9
expressed and delivered inside the cell
to get the most kind of hit and run at
the target and such that cast 9 and the
machinery isn't around to bind to off
target sites and that's where the the
simplex strategy may be potentially a
bit better than the transient selection
strategy because I think the simplest is
only around for probably the first two
to three days at most
whereas I think the transient selection
method is longer most plasmid based
systems and take a few extra days of
cast net expression so that's one of the
reasons why my lab really likes some of
the protein methods because you don't
have to rely on post machinery but you
also have a limited window in which
cutting is happening just because the
protein is being degraded
okay great thank you we have another
question here and a question is how will
empathetic memory affect patient-derived
IPSC cells compared to embryonic cells
well I think that's something that we
didn't directly discuss today but in
memory if it can bias the types of
lineages that you see as well as
particular genes that get turned on or
turned off through the reprogramming and
differentiation process so we have not
seen much epigenetic memory at least in
the types of assays that we've been
looking at but we haven't really looked
very thoroughly also genome-wide for
memory
okay here is actually uh here's a
question actually that with relativity
is is there a possibility of undesirable
insertions using the simplex methodology
yes the possibility is certainly there
it is hard to track and this is a
challenge for almost every single
strategy that relies on a donor template
so you know you could you could design
your probes and look for them through
some sort of amplification step in the
in the genome
afterwards we haven't had success in
those types of assays and therefore we
have we don't have great data to talk
about off target insertion of these SSO
DNS I think there's a general sense in
the field that the single-stranded all
of those insert less than the
double-stranded templates and thus 1
another reason why we like the kind of
single-stranded approach
okay great
or is another question here crisper has
an obvious advantage over lentivirus
derived IPS ease reprogramming but can
Chris probably use for we combined or
adding transcription factors into DNA
so I mean I think the there's a few
recent papers that talked about using a
dead calf nine meaning one that doesn't
cut the genome but it's fused to
transcriptional activators or epigenetic
writers I think there's one story out of
Duke out of Charlie Garza respects lab
that showed that you could reprogram
cells using that type of dead cast nine
strategy and there's there's a few other
reports out there trying to do precise
genome editing to write in a
transcription factor for reprogramming I
have not seen that there are I think I
think the the episome old strategies
though that we use avoid some of those
integration issues
when you want to write in a
transcription factor so right I've had
at what point I think if I wanted to do
reprogramming using CRISPR I would
probably go to a dead cat 9 strategy
okay
and I have I think we have time probably
for one or two more questions as you see
here on the University therapeutic use
of IPS CS in the near future beyond
disease modeling goals yes there are
clinical trials I think already underway
in the eye and there are also biotech
companies and others trying to generate
a kind of allergenic approaches from my
PSL such that you can modify the immune
response to have a kind of a more
universal
transplant cell so I think there's a lot
of interest in being able to generate
interesting cell therapies from a
pluripotent stem cell platform
okay and yep I have another question
here do you have do you have reduced the
off-target effect significantly with
this new simplex methodology you
probably have already answered that but
that is a question here
yeah so I the off target effects going
back to the kind of four ways of
precision slide is something that we
looked at and I think we don't have
great of evidence to say that slower I
think what is safe to say and more
conservative to say is that is
comparable as standard methods I think
the major story here that I wanted to
convey is that the on target spectrum of
sequence outcomes that you get is much
more defined specifically to what you
wanted in your repair template using the
strategies that I talked about and
therefore at least in the stem cell
workflow you have to screen through a
lot less clones and that I think is one
of the bottlenecks hear that because
stem cells grow relatively slowly
compared to some of the other cell lines
and can also obtain genomic
instabilities upon extended culture and
stress it's favorable to be able to have
a more condensed more efficient workflow
to find the edits that you get at the
intended target site okay great thank
you so with that I think I would like to
want to thank you Chris for your
presentation and let people know too
that before we go that the seminar
webinar will be available for on-demand
viewing through February of 2019 so we
do thank you again for joining us and we
hope that you do check into other events
today throughout the rest of today's
event and enjoy your viewing thank you
everyone your press yep thank you